John hind claims I owe him a
$100 I know you two made a bet about
something I can't remember what it was
he's claiming now that Ken Jennings the
host of Jeopardy is now the permanent
host and we had a bet I said to him John
there is no way Ken Jennings will be the
host of Jeopardy he is not going to be
the next host of Jeopardy and John said
I'll bet you 100 bucks I said fine turns
out Ken Jennings and mayam B were chosen
that's not funny May and
Bale they were chosen together in tandem
he was not the host he was a co-host
only host that's right when this
happened they tried a bunch of different
people and I said that Ken was going to
be the host which you disagreed with you
thought it was Stephanopoulos or
somebody else and thought it should be
George
Stephanopoulos which which it wasn't it
was Ken Jennings and wait it was that
other producer before it was ever Ken
Jennings look Mike Richards was not the
full-time host it was trouble from day
one he never got the gig he got the gig
not really and he gave it to himself it
doesn't count Ken you know Emmy
nominated by the way Ken Jennings now he
was always the full-time host and that
was what I
said who was the host when Alex tbec was
there cuz he hosted every kind of
Jeopardy all right I what I'm going to
do I'll stand by whatever M says CU
Robin's bias toward me let me m doesn't
like me by the way come on you started
this whole argument with Howard being
right I think you're both nerds I find
this whole argument annoying send me the
money be my ruling no we need ruling
come on I'm I'm asking you if you're
uncomfortable I'll go to JD and JD is
John will JD will give the right answer
I can guarantee you that I think the guy
was sort of on the outs the the producer
or whatever and so they were looking for
like like the producer the producer got
the job when we after we made the B wait
a minute
J JD is making perfect sense keep here
is the timeline mayam BL took up
Jeopardy hosting duties in 2021
alongside the show's executive producer
named Mike Richards producer Mike
Richards was repl reped by Jennings
later in
2021 after offensive comments he had
previously made surfaced and forced him
to step down I right this was all
before anyone was
named JD go ahead I'm waiting for your
ruling tell the truth JD that's all we
set you free I I mean this is kind of
lame I would almost call it a draw
because in a way why is it a draw JD
don't you hate it when a referee ruins
the game by making a bad call yeah well
influence by don't be influ selected who
was selected to be the host of Jeopardy
it was John are you honest going to take
a hundred bucks from me when you're
clearly wrong that Ken Jennings was not
appointed host was right I mean
eventually in in July 27th 2022 I have
an article Mayan biic and Ken Jen
named permanent Jeffy hosts that's right
2022 there was another selection but in
2021 Mike Richards was named permanent I
don't know if that was that wasn't
necessarily a select it was a
shortterm not all right so you're so
you're R let look up an article Mike
Richard are you ruling for John hold on
a second hold on a second show executive
producer hold
on
August
2021 uh what is this New York 1 Jeopardy
Producer Mike Richards named host of
iconic game show oh I didn't see my $100
Howard can I just jump in the I'm
looking at the article and it's from
August 11th but JD maybe you missed it
after weeks of celebrity tryouts leaks
and heat of speculation Mike Richards
and actor mayam B have been named
permanent co-hosts of Jeopardy thank
marking the first time two people will
host one of television's most popular
game show that is from August 11th of
2021 what was the date that the BET was
made so someone that's what I want to
know someone says don't disappear you
just buried me don't you got to get back
on here dude I'm reading the facts I'm
reading the facts says someone says it
was during the Alex TCO bit so I'm
assuming that was before all the Ken
Rich whatever so bet I didn't bet I
didn't bet after the guy was named host
in that case uh
goes towards Howard and I would have to
Ru of
course John you're you're acting like JD
made the wrong decision why JD was
clearly strong armed by the People by
fact by facts he was strong armed he
didn't have all the facts he trusted you
Howard I will send you $100 I don't want
send it to char No I will send you
$100
now